[Music]
so
this new mom in the uk is getting up to
twelve thousand dollars in damages for
not getting invited to a
christmas like drinks like get together
so she got left out while she was on
maternity leave so she was left out
from her friends and then she sued them
from her co-workers
while she was on maternity leave they
all went out for christmas drinks
she didn't get invited and now she won
twelve thousand dollars oh so she sued
the company
yes oh damn why uh
i know why they didn't invite her you
know sounds like a kind of person you
don't wanna invite they're gonna sue you
for not inviting me yeah that's pretty
pretty up there so it's really
interesting because the judge accepted
that there was no deliberate decision to
exclude her
but ruled that the reason she was not
invited
was that no one thought about her had
she been at work around this time she
would have certainly been invited
she was overlooked because she was on
maternity leave but doesn't the judge
also just see this case and go
[ __ ] this [ __ ] yeah he still has to rule
off yeah like
i dismiss this [ __ ] give me a real case
people really have problems
it's expensive to get sued too like you
even just to fill out a paper that says
you're innocent yeah or whatever is like
350 400 dollars
how do you go back to work after that
and not feel ashamed right
yeah well so then the judge said that
the couple kind of [ __ ]
person does that so oh oh because this
will happen so then the company
uh was also ruled to have discriminated
against her by finding its financial
struggles
or sorry by hiding its financial
struggles because they apparently this
was back in 2018
that they didn't have a proper christmas
party because they were struggling
financially and so instead they put 275
uh behind a bar at a local pub and
that's why they went out for drinks
instead of having an actual christmas
party so then they said
but because of the company hiding its
financial struggles and then with her
having no idea she would be made
redundant soon after returning
from her leave that that's why she
deserves this compensation
okay that makes sense okay because i was
like if you already know your company's
struggling and you find that out why the
[ __ ] would you sue it
for more for the money that it doesn't
have a grievance well because like as
soon as she came back from relief they
they ended up firing her anyway that
makes sense so she's like [ __ ] it
yeah yeah yeah so then uh they're saying
that
the compensation up to twelve thousand
dollars would be a
likely award for injury to feelings the
firm was also ordered to pay to
compensate her
for one thousand four hundred dollars in
unpaid wages and holiday pay hold up
you could get paid for her field yeah
how the [ __ ] do you i prove that i'm
gonna owe a lot of [ __ ] money
she also time to take out insurance for
that i know
i also need to get paid too so how does
that work yeah
well you're feeling sorry too right
isn't like emotional damages that's hurt
feelings right
[ __ ] i would be like [ __ ] i got hurt too
right i will see you back
yeah right isn't emotional damage is the
same thing they just worded it
differently
people is emotional too [ __ ] dude that's
stressful yeah
and getting sued she was also seeking
compensation
for a colleague mocking her for naming
her baby presley after elvis presley but
that claim was dismissed
god damn this [ __ ] is like a different
level of petty
she just made a list yeah and
something's stuck in some things dude
they talked about me
okay you have something to say
yeah you don't have anything to say you
don't want to talk to me i want to see a
picture of this baby maybe the judge
said
he does look like elvis overruled
he's like yup he's right yeah
this lady is a sad sad one 12 000 bucks
that's crazy well what's maternity leave
like you get paid
to being pregnant right did you get to
chill no it's after you have the baby
oh okay so then you pop the baby out oh
it's like leading up to it
and then yeah well you can choose when
to take the six weeks so some women work
all the way up to
they're popping out the baby and then
they take the whole six weeks or after
or you could split it up it's usually
six weeks but some companies end up
giving you more
in canada i think it's paid like a year
or something and the government
subsidizes it so if you're
that's why they got happy kids yeah so
if the company uh lets
the um they have maternity leave and
then they'll get paid back by
the government damn that's cool there's
some countries where
it's they get both parents get yeah
fraternity and maternity leave
scandinavian country or something right
yeah so who works then
no no they're getting just getting paid
by the government at home with their kid
i mean what if all of them have babies
at the same time
and then it's like who's gonna work in
the company
it's a campbell baby that's cool i mean
if it works right
or maybe they get some kind of money
from the government and it kind of works
that way
well they have a different tax system
set up too so i don't know
true that's true it's a whole different
world yeah and six weeks always seems so
short
yeah it's like so little time it's like
a little over a month
that's it that's nothing you're you have
to leave your newborn baby after a month
and a half of that being alive you're
still healing man you're going back into
work with the [ __ ] broken [ __ ] still
yeah
wait when's it supposed to heal it's
ripped up and destroyed it's not it's
gonna take at least two months
two months thanks for explaining my
vagina to me you're welcome it looks
like a flat tire i'm just talking about
um tears and wounds right
two women that had kids they could
probably have a torn vagina
there are other ways of having children
i like to guess okay does it really
matter i don't know you guys can answer
and then but i like to guess and see if
i was right or wrong
you're not guessing you're explaining
you're a man he said you can answer
her i heard the vagina and torah you
heard it what did it sound like
really wait really though no i heard it
so bart you're the professional how do
how long does it take the vagina to heal
um i think good two months that's fine
was i right if i put money on it what i
would what i would would have wouldn't i
honestly
didn't even hear anything you said i
said around two to three months it
should start to
like feel like it's i mean if within the
first month i mean you're
you're bleeding for an entire month um
and then so
after that you're still killing so maybe
three months i mean it's gonna be tender
for maybe six months
oh why didn't you why don't you record
this stuff they tell you you can't have
sex for like eight weeks right
it's like eight weeks some people go
right away huh it's really just
how fast you heal honestly i don't
remember for me because i had a
c-section
i remember it was different rules but i
did still bleed a whole month
i remember that through your vagina
still yeah i mean yes
because yeah i imagine that your body
doesn't know if it's having a period
and some shit's happening like i don't
know a whole month of bleeding
maybe there's still blood that was in
the areas that you had to drain
do you think even doctors when they're
learning about this [ __ ] like
about the female body doing all this
[ __ ] they're like this in class like
they shouldn't be doctors then like this
yeah i don't know how to hear this [ __ ]
without going like i know
bart said he would be dissecting some
[ __ ] and eating lunch at the same time
and i'm like
what like just the [ __ ] juices that
they
like [ __ ] prepare this thing and
smells like it doesn't smell good
you just gotta separate them i feel like
i've never been bothered enough to
to not eat my food like i could watch
the grossest [ __ ] and still you've heard
i can't do that okay i feel like you're
gonna be this nasty but have you ever
eaten while taking a [ __ ] ew don't have
to answer all oh god
wait why did you ask have you done that
no but she it's just her have to refuel
it's going okay you guys have no idea
how trash she is
you're trash
i can't even bring a pretzel into the
bathroom i see why you have two
bathrooms i gotta know i have eaten
while doing a bat like taking a bath and
that to me is like
it took me a minute to like wait about
that does that relax like a strawberry
oh yeah yeah but like the water though
it does like
it made my stomach feel weird like
pressured and then like me trying to eat
like it was pushing it back out it
depends on what it is because if you're
if you're in a bathtub eating flamin hot
cheetos i'm judging you white cheddar
cheez-its is my go-to
they used to do that in roman baths they
had a feast while in the bath
a bath is different than when you're
taking a [ __ ] there's just dude
i'm in the middle of an activity and
maybe bart can relate i am already
contracted
today what is this okay so if i'm
journaling
and i have to go i'm bringing that
journal with me i'm drinking my coffee
i'm bringing it with me if i'm eating my
cheez-its i'm bringing it with me i
don't do that i don't like to stop my
activities you know what i like that
you're real
yeah so you're in between bites you're
done you're wiping your [ __ ]
no no not in between bites you set it
down
baby close your eyes and then then you
wipe not your eyes your ears
and then you wash your hands and then
you pick up the cheese and then you go
back to the cheeses
like it's on the there's a counter yeah
but you're eating as you're on the
toilet
yeah like i would understand your logic
if it was like a meal that you just
can't get you're
like a sandwich sometimes i'm an episode
but you're eating [ __ ] that you can eat
that's not going to get cold that you
can buy
like and you don't want to interrupt
okay the activity
i like it i like it you do it's like
getting thanksgiving dinner and you're
like i gotta go take a [ __ ]
you gotta [ __ ] trade and you [ __ ]
put on your lap and you're just cutting
steak
and you're taking a dump to use the
restroom in the middle of me eating the
meal like
okay i come back i don't bring the meal
with me but after i come back
i don't even have an appetite anymore no
because you're just [ __ ] yeah so i
can't exactly why i can't just stop in
the middle of activity either i'm
finishing at the table and then going
after
or but i wouldn't bring a whole meal it
was only a snack or a salad don't start
acting like you got [ __ ] parameters
now i
do i wouldn't like be cutting with a
knife and a fork yeah you haven't found
the right meal to do that yet
but you're this [ __ ] close to doing
it i told you to close your ears i
turned down the volume on my soul
okay holy [ __ ] she can't take a [ __ ] no
it's just imagining her eating cheez-its
how do you lose your appetite after
taking a [ __ ] my appetite gets higher
me too because no it's like it in my
mind i'm like i have more space now
i can't even because you're a [ __ ]
cartoon bro i have more space now i can
go
and eat more that's some cartoon thing i
can't even have a cup
in the bathroom if i if i go to the
bathroom and then i have to get rid of
the cup
i can't have a cup that had like if i'm
drinking water you know this
if i'm drinking water and it's exposed
right like if i leave that cup overnight
you know there's [ __ ] particles okay
so i do not drink it
in my mind my butt is so big it's
covered on particles
it's not there's particles coming out
wow nice
it works i don't even think about
particles it's more like
smelling my own [ __ ] while i'm eating
that's gonna kill my own appetite
you're not a little [ __ ] like the rest
of us in this group my [ __ ] doesn't
smell that's your guys's problem
my [ __ ] doesn't smell either no but
that's lottery though sometimes it does
and sometimes it doesn't
and i don't want to take that chance
you've never had you've never had like
heavy mickey your [ __ ] smells like look
at you you know what i think
i think they both love the smell of
their [ __ ] so like it doesn't smell it's
delightful
it's poo pourri is that when you're in
it you can't smell it but if you go out
and then you come back
to the bathroom then you're like who
went in there really
i smell it as soon as it dumps wait have
you ever pooped
not into water oh that's the true
test that does not work swirls or just
out in the woods you poop
emojis just out in the woods yeah dude
outdoor shooting is probably one of the
best things
it really is it smells it's so good that
my buddy
gets tissue paper and as we're
snowboarding he pulls off to the side
and he goes into the mountains to take a
[ __ ]
in in the middle of the slope you'd
rather do that than use the bathroom at
the bottom
it's so good that it's a slope no he
does instead of stopping at the gas
station to take a piss and [ __ ] he has a
pocket full of napkins
and then while we are like adventuring
he runs outside and takes a [ __ ] in the
desert
so where does he put the napkins you
bury oh yeah
sir can you not defecate on our slope
please
gasoline gas station every [ __ ]
bathrooms are horrifying
i'd rather go more girls at the gas
station than he does okay i wouldn't eat
in a gas station bathroom
yes you would stop it unless it's in a
bag
how classy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you